hey guys it's Charlotte McKinney here  shooting in LA for GQ magazine  the best or worst place to pick someone  up would have to be to be honest is  really not a good or bad place if you're  the right guy I'd take a risk anywhere  the best pick-up line I've ever heard  was if he drives like well I'd really  like to get your number I guess it was  kind of a turn-on my ideal first date  something super mellow dinner with a  view I do get a little nervous on dates  so good cocktail good company like I  wish guys knew that don't really know  when a girl says everything's fine she's  usually lying we really do want your  attention and we do want to feel like  you care so I don't think guys would  really pick up on it because we kind of  blow it off but keep trying  we're psycho we're freaking crazy  get your Lambo out of here we're doing  in a real  well guys I'm Charlotte McKinney thanks  for watching and go check out some more  videos I'm Chi Chi's youtube channel